The restoration of the Sistine Chapel began in 1980 and ended in 1994.
After this immense work,...
...no one thought that Michelangelo's masterpiece could be seen any better until now.
With a new lighting system installed in the chapel,...
...visitors can enjoy the paintings in a whole new light.
Before the installation, some details of the "Creation of Adam" were barely recognizable.
Now they can clearly be seen with vivid colors.
Thanks to the 7,000 LED light points,...
...all the details and figures from this work of art gain life and expression.
Those who have visited the chapel for over 500 years can say...
...that his masterpiece looks as if it was painted yesterday.